[Music]
what is up everybody it's
adamak here for anime uproar and in this
video we're going to be talking about
everything we know so far about one
punch man season 2 and the reason that I
decided to make this video was that we
have been getting a whole bunch of
questions and comments about one punch
man season 2 when is it coming out is it
really coming out this year and so on
and in the past few weeks there have
been a whole bunch of rumors going
around in social media and on online
media websites about one punch man
season 2 a lot of it is confusing a lot
of it is not credible some of these
media sources are not credible
legitimate sources so what I decided to
do was to put all of the credible
information everything we know and all
the credible rumors here in one place so
that you know everything that we know so
far we already made similar videos for
code geass season 3 and 7 Deadly Sins
season 2 and those were really well
received so we decided to do one for one
punch man as well remember that here at
anime uproar we want to be your number
one source for all the latest news and
theories in the world of anime so be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you can be the
first to know every time we get some new
information now we know that multiple
news sources have been reporting that
one punch man season 2 is confirmed to
be coming out sometime in 2017 although
we do not have an official release date
yet in September of last year the
official one punch man Twitter account
confirmed that one punch man season 2 is
in production according to Kevin Hamrick
Senior Director for sales and marketing
and viz media a second season of one
punch man will be coming out later this
year and even though we don't have an
exact release date yet a bunch of recent
rumors are speculating that one punch
man season 2 could show up sometime in
mid 2017
perhaps in July which would be the
second anniversary of one punch man
season 1 however even though I hope that
these rumors are true and I really love
the show and I can't wait for season 2
don't get your hopes up just yet we know
that the anime industry can be tricky
just look at how long we were waiting
for attack on Titan see
we are still waiting for 7w send season
two so until we have an exact official
confirmation don't get your hopes up
because you never know but whatever
happens here at anime Opera we're going
to stay on top of it so stay tuned and
we will let you know as soon as we get
new information and now that we covered
the news I'm going to talk about some
potential plot points for one punch man
season 2 based on the various different
arcs in the manga now these are going to
be just some general teasers about
potential plot arcs in the second season
however if you don't want any manga
spoilers then you can leave right now
and for the rest of you the first plot
point that we might be dealing with in
season two is saitama's life being in
danger because on my mask discovers the
true source of Saitama power and decides
to use this to his advantage
so my mask is one potential rival for
Saitama in the second season and the
second potential rival is s-class rank 7
hero both void the metal night we all
remember when in the first season a
meteor was about to strike Z City and
the metal knight was not concerned about
saying the city only about the
efficiency of his new missiles also in
season 1 we recall that dry night
secretly told jenos that the metal knife
cannot be trusted with anything the
metal knight dedicated his life to
finding new high-end technology and he
might be able to use the items he
collected from dark matter thieves ship
to become more powerful and a bigger
rival to cite them other potential plot
points include a connection coming to
light between s-class rank 7 hero King
and Saitama a connection that could
explain why King is so successful while
Saitama gets no recognition whatsoever
in addition new heroes might have to be
recruited in order to deal with some new
threats including some very unlikely
heroes and finally we might find out
just how badass a disciple of silver
Fang can be and that is it for this
video as always thank you so much for
watching and a big thank you to soul
maka for helping me out with this one
again soul maka helps me a lot all the
time and you can find them on our
discord he's a great guy if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell for all the
latest anime
News and theories and if you want to
chat with us on a daily basis you can
join our discord server the link is in
the description and until next time see
ya bass Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]